LIBERTY & LEVIN."
[♪♪♪]
STEVE: BREAKING TONIGHT.
BIG NEWS ON PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
IRAN STRATEGY.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE COULDN'T
CARE LESS IF THEY NEGOTIATE
DESPITE WHAT HIS NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR SAID THIS
MORNING.
THE PRESIDENT REITERATING HIS
INSISTENCE IRAN WILL NOT GET A
NUCLEAR WEAPON AND SURGING IRAN
NOT TO KILL PROTESTERS AS
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE TOOK TO THE
STREETS TO CONDEMN THEIR LEADERS
FOR SHOOTING DOWN A UKRAINIAN
PASSENGER PLANE.
I WILL BE JOINED BY MATT GAETZ
FOR REACTION.
LOOK AT THIS.
TAMMY BRUCE, LISA BOOTHE,
LAWRENCE JONES.
KT McFARLAND COMING UP ON
IRAN.
I'M STEVE HILTON, THIS IS "THE
NEXT REVOLUTION."
FRIDAY NANCY PELOSI CAVED AGAIN
SAYING THEY WILL SEND ARTICLES
OF IMPEACHMENT TO THE SENATE IN
A FEW DAYS.
IRAN CONFIRMED IT SHOT DOWN THE
UKRAINIAN PASSENGER PLANE.
HERE IS HOW I SEE THINGS SAT THE
END OF A ME MEN TO
END OF AOME MEN TO
END OF AO D MEN TO
END OF AO D -EN TO
END OF AO D --N TO
END OF AO D -- TTO
END OF AO D -- THE END OF A
MOMENTOUS WEEK FOR THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
I DON'T THINK THERE HAS BEEN
PROPER RECOGNITION OF THE
SUBSTANCE WHAT THIS PRESIDENT IS
DOING.
IT DOESN'T FIT INTO THE
ESTABLISHMENT TRADITIONAL
IDEOLOGICAL BOXES.
THAT'S WHY THEY WASTE OUR TIME
WITH POINTLESS POLITICAL GAMES
WITH IMPEACHMENT.
THE DEMOCRATS, NEVER TRUMPERS
AND THEIR LACKEYS BRANDED HIM A
WAR MONGER.
BUT HIS STRATEGY HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT WITH DAY ONE.
HE'S ANTI-WAR, BUT HE'S ALSO
ANTI-WEAK.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO PUT HIS HEAD
IN THE STAND LIKE THE ISOLATION
NUTS.
HE WAS THE SAME OVER SYRIA.
A MISSILE STRIKE IF YOU USE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
YOU SAW IT IN NORTH KOREA.
FIRE AND FURY, THEN
NEGOTIATIONS.
THE SAME WITH CHINA.
THEY ARE COMING HERE NEXT WEEK
TO SIGN A DEAL.
THIS IS THE TRUMP REVOLUTION.
PRAGMATIC.
NON-IDEOLOGICAL.
HE APPROACHES ISSUES AS A
BUSINESSMAN.
IT'S A REVOLUTION IN IDEAS.
HE'S COMBINING THE BEST OF
TRADITIONAL CONSERVATIVE IDEAS
WITH POSITIVE POPULISM.
APPOINTING CONSERVATIVE JUDGES
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM,
CUTTING TAXES AND BOOSTING
FAMILY LEAVE.
CUTTING REGULATIONS GIVING A
MASSIVE BOOST WITH PLANS TO
REFORM THE BUREAUCRACY AND
CUTTING LOW WAGE IMMIGRATION.
WE SEE NEW CHAPTERS EVERY MONTH.
ANOTHER POSITIVE JOBS REPORT
FRIDAY.
UNEMPLOYMENT AT A 50-YEAR LOW.
EARNINGS RISING, NOT JUST FOR
EVERYONE, BUT FASTEST FOR THE
LOWEST PAID, ENDING NEARLY 50
YEARS OF STAGNATION.
HOW ARE THE ESTABLISHMENT
REPUBLICANS REACTING?
>> DONALD TRUMP RAN AS A
CELEBRITY AS HAS BECOME THE
WORST PRESIDENT IN HISTORY.
>> NORMAL WORKING AMERICANS ARE
SAD AND EMBARRASSED AND
EXHAUSTED.
>> THE VAST MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS DON'T THINK HE'S DOING
A GOOD JOB.
THINK HE'S A BAD PRESIDENT.
THINK HE'S COMPROMISED BY A
FOREIGN POWER.
THINK HE'S DISHONEST AND THINK
HE'S LAWLESS WHICH OF COURSE HE
IS.
HE'S AN AWFUL REPRESENTATIVE NOT
ONLY TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
BUT THE HUMAN RACE.
STEVE: THE NEVER TRUMPERS
PUBLISHED A MANIFESTO IN THE
"NEW YORK TIMES."
AS AMERICANS WE NEED TO STEM THE
DAMAGE HE AND HIS FOLLOWERS ARE
DOING TO THE RULE OF LAW, THE
CONSTITUTION AND AMERICAN
CHARACTER.
WHO BROUGHT IN THE DISASTROUS
IMMIGRATION REFORM CREATING THE
SYSTEM TRUMP IS TRYING TO FIX.
WHO BROUGHT CHINA INTO THE WORLD
TRADE ORGANIZATION WHERE WE
CAN'T EVEN PRINT BIBLES IN
AMERICA.
PUTTING SO MANY AMERICANS OUT OF
WORK IN THE HEARTLAND.
AND WHO ASSAULTED THE AMERICAN
FAMILY WITH POLICIES THAT
COLLAPSED MARRIAGE RATES AND
FAMILY STABILITY.
NOT THE EVIL TRUMP.
IT WAS YOU THE REPUBLICAN
ESTABLISHMENT WHO DID THIS TO
AMERICA.
THESE NEVER TRUMPERS ARE APOLL
JIFTS AND THEY ARE ANTI-FAMILY
AND ANTI-COMMUNITY.
THEY CAN WRITE WHATEVER NONSENSE
THEY WANT IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
THE REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT
PARTY IS NOT COMING BACK.
THERE IS NO CONSTITUENCY FOR
THEIR IDEAS SEPTEMBER
OPPORTUNISTS -- EXCEPT
OPPORTUNISTS.
>> I BELIEVE HE'S THE HAMBURGER
EATING ZAMBONI RIDING LOON WE
SEE ON TWITTER.
STEVE: THEY HAVE POWDERED WIGS
AND FAKE BEAUTY SPOTS AS THEY
SAY TRUMP IS SO VULGAR.
MAYBE HE IS, BUT IF YOU GOT A
JOB AFTER FIVE YEARS ON THE
SCRAP HEAP, YOU WILL TAKE THAT.
IF YOU ARE A PATRIOT STAND UP TO
CHINA.
YOU WILL COME TO THE SAME